quel épisode mais quel épisode
je ne sais pas vous mais ça me fait
clairement bizarre de me dire que la
série est maintenant terminée en neuf
épisodes et surtout que wendat épouse
parfaitement son rôle et sa puissance
qui avait été mis sous silence depuis
son apparition dans et joe filtrons le
mc u est clairement relancer de nouveaux
chapitres s'écrivent et il est grand
temps de mettre en lumière ce grand
final
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
louper aucune des prochaines vidéos
allez on commence sans tarder à chercher
les réponses du dernier épisode
tout d'abord la scène de la
confrontation entre les deux visions et
insein la métaphore du bateau de taizé
était top mais maintenant il se passe
quoi pourquoi vision est parti tout
d'abord le wait vision est une grosse
référence aux comics tout comme dans la
série
ce dernier a été démantelé puis
reconstruit par la suite dans les comics
c'est hank pym qui s'en chargera alors
qu'ici bas assez hayward avec le sword
mais la similitude est la même suite à
sa reconstruction vision a perdu toutes
ses émotions
il a perdu sa conscience il n'est plus
le même vision qu'à l'origine
et en plus de ça il n'a plus la pierre
de l'esprit ce qui signifie qu'il ne
peut plus véritablement évolué comme il
l'avait fait dans infinity ward il a été
résistant son côté émotionnel ce qui
explique pourquoi il est parti après le
combat il n'a pas oublié au rwanda mais
il ne ressemble plus rien pour elle ni
pour quiconque
et chose intéressante sous une autre
forme dans les comics anti vision ce
dernier a été programmé pour combattre
les avengers tout comme hayward l'a fait
pour rwanda et suite à tout ça quand il
a repris sa véritable nature
il est juste parti également et a tenté
de se reconstituer une vie donc dans
l'idée il se pourrait clairement qu'on
suive ce même schéma suite à l'arc
wang dhabi jeunes le white vdn pourrait
tenter de se re concis
à peu près normale ou d'être retrouver
sa véritable origine c'est quelque chose
que l'on n'oublie pas mais suite aux
retours de ses souvenirs vision se
rappelle maintenant des événements
dignes finity war et donc de la
tentative de souris de leur programme et
sans la pierre de l'esprit et suite à
ces actions schori à conserver le schéma
originel de vision et elle est la seule
à le posséder un quart tony n'est plus
de ce monde et banner est en quelque
sorte out
il n'est plus dans tout ça et en plus de
ça il n'a pas les compétences pour le
faire tout seul
enfin ce qui serait aussi intéressant
concernant la quête de vision de
retrouver son origine et ses émotions et
qu'ils combattent mentalement ces
mauvaises pensées vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir qu'une partie du tronc vie à
l'intérieur de vision en quelque sorte
puisqu'il est basé sur son programme à
la base et c'est quelque chose de
récurrent dans les comics hull tron
essayent de corrompre vision à plusieurs
reprises étant donné que le white vie
jeunes a perdu sa conscience ses
émotions il est actuellement fragile en
quelque sorte et sa part du le tronc
pourrait faire surface en lui a vous de
me dire ce que vous en pensez
par rapport à monica rambo il n'y a pas
tant que ça de choses à dire pour le
moment en vrai sa scène post générique
et est obligatoire pour donner une
direction aux personnages et
accessoirement tease et un autre film
certainement captain marvel 2 voir la
série secretin les jeunes dont n'avons
pas vraiment encore d'informations pour
le monde c'est évidemment nick fiori qui
l'a appelé comme toujours
ce dernier a des yeux partout
certainement grâce à talos et d'autres
scroll monica ayant aujourd'hui fait ses
preuves et possède ses pouvoirs elle
devient une figure emblématique est
importante pour la suite des événements
surtout qu'elle est liée aux sword et
prochainement le shield néanmoins étant
donné que carole possède déjà le nom de
captain marvel il est fort à parier
qu'elle prenne directement
non de photons en rapport avec ses
pouvoirs du coup bah non celui de
captain marvel
ce qui est intéressant en tout cas et
que nick fury l'appel pour le rejoindre
dans l'espace mais carole devrait lui
suffire normalement non et comme l'a
démontré far from home nick fury ne peut
plus vraiment appeler les autres héros
qui sont tous partis de leur côté la
preuve avec one d'avis jeunes le shield
n'était pas là et monica n'était pas
trop pour intervenir
alors pourquoi la faire partir de la
terre pour l'emmener dans l'espace
peut-être que nick fury aurait décelé
une menace que même carole ne suffirait
pas à vaincre entre guillemets ou bien
peut-être que dans un conflit mental on
va dire monica serait la plus adaptée
pour confronter captain marvel en
rapport avec son passé jouant tout ça
sur le côté affectif
bon j'avoue que par un petit peu loin
mais la question mérite quand même
d'être soulevée et enfin on passe sur le
cas de warda maximov et de l'avenir avec
doctor strange days je m'attendais
vraiment à voir strange je ne vous mens
pas on en a beaucoup parlé dans les
vidéos
mais bon ce que je comprends c'est qu'il
n'arrivera plus tard il doit forcément
arriver néanmoins il ya quand même des
choses hyper cool à relever tout d'abord
cela m'a sauté aux yeux mais dans la
scène post générique le nouveau lieu de
vie de luanda n'est pas du tout un
hasard
j'en suis certain ok il y à l'idée de
les remises à la manière d'obi wan cette
dernière est dans un endroit reculé
isolé de tous et s'entraîne mais pas que
cette chaîne de montagne et pour moi ou
wendat gore wendat gore est le lieu où
le premier
magicien noir de l'histoire stone a
écrit le dark gold désolé de la
prononciation mais nous sommes vraiment
que c'est comme ça compte pour remettre
dans le contexte tonnes pourraient être
quasiment considéré comme un dieu le
dieu du chaos
il est le premier match noir apparu il y
a des milliards d'années pour se
protéger d'une guerre divine en quelque
sorte
il a créé une autre dimension pour s'y
cacher sauf qu'il restera enfermé dedans
à jamais son seul héritage et le dark
pool de en quelque sorte le livre que
possède rwanda et dont elle se sert pour
comprendre ses pouvoirs et du coup vu
que wendat cherche à comprendre cette
magie qu'elle ne connaît pas encore quoi
de mieux que de retourner à son origine
awan d'abord l'endroit où le livre a été
écrit par son auteur d'origine
la présence de la voix des enfants de
wendat pendant sa projection astrale
nous tease clairement le concept de
dimension et réalité différente puisque
le multivers sera la thématique
principale de doctor strange 2 cela
reste mon avis dans tous les cas
néanmoins il pourrait avant tout s'agir
d'un piège comme l'a dit agata wendat a
déclenché quelque chose en réveillant
totalement son pouvoir et comme l'a
démontré son comportement ce pouvoir du
chaos est convoité agatha n'est pas la
seule à désirer ce pouvoir un pouvoir
qui dépasse même les sorciers suprême et
qui peut détruire le monde
c'est la porte ouverte à de nombreux
vilains rwanda étant seul
isolée elle est une cible facile
en quelque sorte l'appel de ces enfants
pourraient donc être le teasing d'un
futur nouvel ennemi le cas méphisto est
toujours probable étant donné qu'il est
un maître dans l'usurpation la perfidie
et l'illusion il pourrait attirer au
rwanda pour essayer d'avoir son pouvoir
en lui proposant pourquoi pas un marché
injuste
il se pourrait également se soit
nightmare c'est antagonistes était à la
base prévu par scott derrickson le
réalisateur de doctor strange et du coup
bas dr strange 2 néanmoins ce dernier a
été écarté pour laisser place à sam
raimi donc qui sait si nightmare est
toujours d'actualité mais du coup comme
son nom l'indiqué il est le seigneur des
cauchemars et donc de la peur et possède
sa dimension des rêves il pourrait
manipuler rwanda et la trouble et
provoquant peut-être le début de sa
folie mais cela pourrait être aussi qu
tonnes même si ça me paraît énorme pour
le moment étant donné que rwanda est en
quête de savoir
agata lui a même dit que c'était son
problème ou en dha pour est allé trop
loin et ouvrir la porte de la dimension
du célèbre magicien noir
ce dernier aurait accès à la terre et
pourraient se déchaîner souhaitant même
récupéré le dark gold qui sait et enfin
dernière info que j'ai oublié d'écrire
et que j'ai pas du tout envie d'oublier
mais on en avait parlé dans le dernier
épisode ce n'est pas la dernière fois
qu'on reverra agatha est là elle le
tease d'elle-même rwanda va avoir besoin
d'elle et si wendat a besoin d'elle elle
peut toujours l'appeler donc une
possible alliance entre les deux
sorcières risque d'arriver à un moment
ou un autre
c'est d'ailleurs un petit peu marrant
dans le comparatif car strange a comme
ennemi mort d'eau et rwanda a comme
ennemi agatha s'est un petit peu leur
vie vaut un petit peu
et les sorciers ennemis c'est un petit
peu marrant ce comparatif en vrai
bref je pense avoir dit le principal
je suis très heureux de vous avoir parlé
de one la vision et je tiens sincèrement
à vous remercier de m'avoir suivi tout
au long des vidéos au fil des épisodes
évidemment ce n'est pas la fin et qui
dit fin de série arrivé de spider man 3
de dr strange deux dit forcément gros
trois théories en perspective un trois
théories accompagné d'un bg ultime que
vous connaissez tous je vais tout faire
pour vous sortir ça la semaine prochaine
en attendant n'hésitez pas à me faire
des retours via l'espace commentaires à
vous abonner pour ne louper aucune des
prochaines vidéos et puis a laissé un
petit pouce bleus 1 c'est toujours un
énorme soutien pour moi écouter cet
argot rock et que le lionheart soit avec
vous allez ciao tout
[Musique]